yeah
so I've had a lot of social anxiety and
some depression for a while most of my
high school experience a lot of that
stems from being gay in a small town
setting I started going to therapy
I got medication and started doing
better went and volunteered at the bird
sanctuary because I liked birds it
became a safe place for me I II ended up
adopting her because she really did I
felt that she helped me and we formed a
bond and she I started noticing how she
helped me I always felt more comfortable
when I had out
I like talking about her it actually
helps with my social anxiety that way
she'll say hello for me it's I don't
know gives me something to talk about
and gives me like a reason to talk to
people which is nice because I didn't
really have a lot of that where I used
to live come here hi I shake her around
a little bit
peekaboo yeah and she'll say peekaboo
that was kind of garbled but I can tell
that she loves me just like I love her
when it comes to mental health the
United States has a long way to go from
caring for those with mental illness to
changing public perceptions and often we